my guest tonight is a five-time all-pro
running back
and although he retired from football
for the second time this past january
he stays busy as a philanthropist social
activist
business owner actor and as of today he
will be available playing the character
in the video game
predator hunting grounds
man he got killed fast please welcome
marshawn beast mode lynch marshawn how
you doing
how are ya
what are you laughing at why are you let
when you just see me you start laughing
why
i don't know what man right now i'm
laughing at a whole lot of different
i'm laughing at the way you keep
throwing your damn hair down like this
it's making me nuts it's crazy
like it's cool between that between
damn he got killed really fast all that
came in my mind was damn why the black
man always die
fast in the scary movies
let's talk about this predator in that
clip
predator kills you really fast were you
playing that when you died that fast
i was oh
god but that's really your voice
screaming right it is you screaming
yeah i did that they call it vo i
learned something
since the last time i seen you i learned
[Laughter]
you know you know i'm in the you know
checking off my bucket list and
vo is something that i didn't know about
but yeah
after i learned i threw that on there so
it worked out for the best
that's great well uh i i like you a lot
i
i i think you're fantastic you're a
gentleman
you're a great man so i don't like
seeing predator kill you
i just don't like it man i meant that's
just for the video game
okay good you bring credit see this is i
just was talking to your people
backstage i say i came
i came to the show i'm not sure if it
was the first or the second one but i
taught you something and i told you you
got a hood pass
and every time you came through the town
if you just said that
you'll be all right i remember this you
told me that if i was ever
in oakland i had a pass that i would
have street cred in
oakland you got to hit them one time
with the one time where they you hit it
and then you gonna be all right
say it again so i i want to learn it
again say it if you hit them with their
you itch
then you're gonna be on you itch
and then and then i'm clean then i'm
good i'm tell you gonna get so much
handshakes and dabs and hoods and
you know marshawn i don't get i don't
get a lot of those i don't get a lot
especially now during coven
ain't nobody getting a lot of them right
now